TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello!
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'm back in the studio
in Mountain View, California.
Let's get caught up with
the coolest developer
news from Google in
the last week or so.
You can now register for
Google Developer Days Europe,
taking place on September
5 and 6 in Poland.
We'll showcase our latest
developer product and platform
updates to help you
develop high-quality apps,
grow and retain an
active user base,
and tap into tools to earn more.
There'll be technical talks,
hands-on training sessions,
and one-on-one time with
Googlers and members
of our Google Developer
Experts community.
The link to register
is on the post.
Also happening in September
is the Google Play Indie Games
Festival in San
Francisco on the 23rd.
If you're an indie developer
based in the US or Canada
and want to submit your
game, you have until August 6
to do so.
Just head on over to the post
linked in the description
below.
We recently launched a developer
preview of the Android Things
console, which allows you to
manage the software running
on your fleet of Android
Things IOT devices,
including creating
factory images
as well as updating
the operating system
and developer-provided APKs.
A tour of the console and
the features it offers
are on the post.
The Google People API
now has write endpoints
that allow you to create,
delete, and update
a single contact as well as
contact group endpoints to read
and write contact groups.
Code and screenshots
are on the post.
Starting with the Firebase
functions module version 0.5.9,
there are now three
new types of database
triggers you can write--
OnCreate, OnUpdate,
and OnDelete.
To see how this can make
your code more efficient,
check out the post.
You can now use the Google
Cloud Platform region in London
to run applications and
store data in London.
This is our 10th region
and joins our existing
European region in Belgium.
Details, including the
available zones and services,
are on the post.
Google Container Engine
now runs Kubernetes 1.7
and includes
differentiated features
for enterprise
security, extensibility,
hybrid networking, and
developer efficiency.
Details are on the post.
As developers, when starting a
new project on the Google Cloud
Platform, you may
find yourself trying
to decide between
different compute options--
Google Compute Engine, Google
Container Engine, App Engine,
or even Google Cloud
Functions and Firebase.
Sound familiar?
If so, this handy
decision tree is for you.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for tuning in to "The Dev
Show," your once again weekly
update on all the coolest
developer news from Google.
If you'd like to catch some
of our previous episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]